After writing the paper, comes the time of reading
your paper a few times in order to get everything
perfect. In this section you will learn how to
remove a lot of mistakes you might have been
writing. In the end, you will have to build your
own checklist corresponding to your own problems
you want to avoid. After this, your article can
be submitted and will hopefully be accepted!!
Let’s discuss the mistakes to
avoid before submitting the paper.
Let’s look at content mistakes. When you
are writing something you want to get people
interested by the content of your article, by
the science behind it, but you also want to
maintain an internal coherent. So, you have to
make sure you answer the following questions:
Do you pass the so what test?
Does the problem statement remain
the same throughout the paper?
Is the title of the paper coherent?
Are the keywords adequate?
Is the content of your research coherent with the
aims and scopes of the journal you are targeting?
The people that are going to read your
article are first the chief editor,
then specialized editor, then the anonymous
reviewers, and finally your community.
Be careful to be coherent and rigorous,
so that they can follow your thinking.
Asking someone else to read your paper once again
is a good idea. He or she will give you his or
her views on how to improve the paper itself,
and more importantly, it can detect mistakes.
This person is going to give you the first set of
tips that one needs before the submission. You can
also check that your article is not boring because
then the peer review process will just eliminate
this paper. You have to keep in mind that your
writing is going to be evaluated by your peers.
Improper language, spelling mistakes,
typos all these are a no go.
You should always be very mindful of your writing
because it can convey the feeling that the paper,
and the authors are not very rigorous
nor up to the journal's standards.
You will want to make sure that everything is
crystal clear, that there is no long sentence,
that you are always writing in an active
voice for English papers and not a passive
one. And there is no need for complicated words,
so just make it simple and straight to the point.
If you are like the rest of us, you will
know it’s hard to correct your own paper.
So, try and find proofreading buddies.
Some friends who will read your paper,
and to whom you will return the favor.
If English is not your native language,
it is always a good idea to use a professional
copy editor. But do it when the final version of
the paper is available, because this service
of language editing is very costly. If you
have submission deadlines, don't forget
to take this time factor into account.
Then there are some common format oversights,
like forgetting the paper's pagination,
something which really frustrates reviewers
since it prevents them from referring to a
specific page in their comments. Also, watch
out for improper bibliographical styles.
Always make sure you know the right
rules for the journal you are targeting.
And always make sure you are
respecting their citing styles.
For that, you can often download a template or the
writing rules on the website or the journal. It is
important to follow the words limit and all the
guidelines that you have to comply with regarding
the paragraphs, the font and the size and so on.
Another important point is the adequate
organization of the paper. Make sure you have
clear sections and subsections as well as short
introduction paragraphs or conclusion.
This helps clarify the argumentation
and makes it easier for the reader to follow.
Also, verify that the titles of sections,
of figures and tables, of the paper itself, are
the right ones. That they correspond exactly to
what you are showing in the paragraph, in the
table, in the figure, and in the paper itself.
If you have specific form requirements in your
discipline, make sure you comply with them.
In order to submit the paper, you also have
to write a cover letter, which is a letter to
the editor describing what you did, in maximum,
one page. The objective is to convince of your
paper's interest. The same basic mistake can
occur in this letter so make sure you write a
well-crafted, interesting, and clear letter.
In the reviewing process we described before,
you will then have to write letters to
the reviewers to answer the comments.
Always be respectful toward them and mindful of
their opinion, recommendation, or critiques. If
they don't understand what you wrote, it is
probably because it was not clear enough. But
here again, if you take care of all the mistakes
that we have defined earlier it should be fine.
In the earlier video on authorship, we
have discussed ICMJE guidelines that help
researchers in deciding whether a contributor
qualifies to be an author or not. In this video,
we are going to discuss the order in which author
names should be included in a multi-author paper.
The order of authors on a scientific paper needs
to be determined after careful deliberation.
Prior to deciding the author order,
it is important to understand the concept
of a first and a corresponding author.
Who should be the first author?
The first author is usually the
person who has made the most significant
intellectual contribution to the work, in
terms designing the study, acquiring and analyzing
data from experiments, and writing the manuscript.
The importance of the first author
is reflected in the common practice
of referring to a paper by the first
author’s name. Publishing a paper as
the first author is very crucial for the
scientific career of a Ph.D. student.
After the first author, the subsequent authors are
usually listed as per their contribution to the
research, starting with the one who contributed
the most to the least. However, sometimes multiple
authors may have contributed equally, in which
case the order of author names does not matter.
What is the role of a corresponding author?
At the time of submission of a manuscript,
journals require you to choose one of
the authors as the corresponding author.
The corresponding author is the one who receives
all notifications from the journal including
manuscript status, reviewers’ comments,
and the final decision. Although journals
usually perceive the role of a corresponding
author as purely administrative, this role is
associated with seniority in some cultures. The
corresponding author is often the group leader
or a senior researcher whose contact address
is not likely to change in the near future.
In cases where the main contributor of the study
is also the group leader, he or she can be both
the first and corresponding author for the study.
Gift authorship
For a student who has been left off an author
list, it can be especially maddening to see
someone included who obviously doesn't deserve it.
Also called "honorary," or "guest," authors, gift
authors don't make a significant contribution (or
sometimes any contribution at all) to the paper.
Motivations for gift authorship
vary; the principal investigator
(PI) may think he's doing the recipient a
favor, or she or he may think that adding
the name of a well-known scientist will improve
the odds of getting published in a top journal.
Gift authors can appear anywhere on the author
list, but usually they're listed in the middle.
Gift authorship is especially damaging when the
recipient is a senior author. Anyone who doesn't
realize that the authorship is honorary will
wrongly assume that this well-known scientist
has performed his or her role in ensuring the
integrity of the data. Sometimes authorships are
even "gifted" without the recipient's knowledge.
In summary, As you can see, choosing the author
order can be quite complicated; therefore, we
urge researchers to consider these factors early
in the research process and to confirm this order
while editing your manuscript before submission
to journals. Don’t wait until the manuscript is
drafted before you decide on the author order.
All the parties involved will need to
agree on the author list before submission,
and no one will want to delay submission
because of a disagreement about who should
be included on the author list and in what
order. Additionally, we recommend periodically
revisiting the named author issue to make sure
that everyone is on the same page and that the
list is updated to appropriately reflect changes
in team composition or contributions to a work.